today the State Board of Education met
virtually to talk about the return to
school this fall following the pandemic
shut down Kirsten Joyce now joining us
live in studio with a recap of the hours
long meeting here it certainly was Brian
the overall sentiment in today's meeting
was listening to superintendents from
across the state on what happened in
their districts when schools closed and
looking ahead to reopening our schools
in the fall CCSD superintendent dr.
hey-zeus jar shared some staggering
numbers with the board he said out of
the approximate 325 thousand students in
the district teachers have not been able
to make any contact with about 4200
children
another concern jarred discussed is the
Summer Slide combined with what's now
being called the kovat slide when
students simply forget what's already
been taught because they're out of
school as of today the district is still
planning on being back in the classroom
come August 10th health and wellness of
our students and our employees will be
the top priority so I don't have an
answer of what's going to what school is
going to look like because we we don't
know what the guidelines from the CDC as
they'll continue to tell us so I just
wanted it gerrae also told the board
that by June 30th he will have a plan
with dates dealing with the reopening
process for CCSD and as for all those
surveys we all filled out due June 1st
those results will be available June
11th the week from today at the next
board meeting